hi everyone Spencer here and today we're
looking at Ghost Recon wildlands in this
playthrough we're going to show the game
with no HUD on we're going to see if
this brings us more into the world of
Ghost Recon what do you guys think with
no HUD on feel free to leave a comment
down below and if you enjoyed this video
feel free to like share and subscribe
for more let's get this mission underway
I got another that's five
iZON to sicarios pour them out inside
the bar
coming up on a toy farm remember a load
of these sicarios are ex-military ID
your targets bomber who gets killed by a
stray round Operation Kingslayer I'll be
dead in the water before it even starts
let's go
sallowness a katana heat seekers who
champion Kuno piranha
what this case over here
good
a little
get cooking weapon
[Music]
persona que no tiene éxito camisa Konami
quality back
say alguien más música for a second that
I guess co-champion no no piranhas
but the earnestness even is where the
cameraman battle keep it quiet
in America they're gonna be on top of us
in another few seconds what do we do
firing up with a key best jaws
shuttlecock well they could meet a
muffin man
marking a tango leaves lifts that local
frag out
get some
are you Amaru what's left of him anyway
come on we're getting you out of here